[Música]
me gustaría que imaginarán ahora que
usted están viviendo en el año 78 y son
efectivos de ibm en ese año la empresa
más grande de computación está todo
domina el mercado y de pronto suena una
alarma le dicen que hay una compañía que
es 23 mil veces más chica y que en unos
20 años amenazara a su posición
ustedes desesperados piden una foto de
qué compañía es y le manda en estas
fotos
ustedes se preocuparían
me lo recordó sean a bill gates
chiquitito
hoy día microsoft es cinco veces más
grande que ibm en valor de mercado
realmente también es cinco veces más
grande que ibm google salvo que los
fundadores de google en ese momento
tenían cinco años si no conseguimos
fotos
lo que nos dedicamos a pie sabemos una
sola cosa quedarnos quietos es decir
para atrás
no arriesgarnos es lo peor que nos puede
pasar la zona de confort no es
confortable
yo voy a usar una metáfora que a mí me
gusta mucho cuando uno trabaja en
tecnología se tiene que sentar como
tarzán se tiene que sentir como tarzán
moviéndose en la selva tarzán se
acuerdan las viejas películas se movía
en la selva saltando de liana en liana
nosotros vamos de una tecnología a otra
y vamos saltando como tarzán en la selva
vamos evolucionando y nos movemos con
rapidez hasta donde hasta donde nos da
la longitud de la liana o la capacidad
de la tecnología el problema número uno
si tarzán quiere agarrar la siguiente
llana y no deja la allianz anterior se
quedó colgado en la selva eso lo que nos
pasa cuando nos quedamos viviendo entre
dos tecnologías si no abandonamos la
anterior el problema número dos
agarramos la liana equivocada no está
bien sujeta al árbol
y terminamos con un buen chillón
y con nuestro orgullo totalmente espera
todo está este viaje empieza en los años
60 con las grandes computadoras las
grandes computadoras costaban decenas de
miles centenas de miles de dólares
la computadora típica de esa época tenía
8 kilobytes de capacidad hoy en día
cualquiera de ustedes tiene en el
bolsillo su celular algo que es más de
un millón de veces más potente que las
computadoras la evolución es el
microprocesador es la capacidad de poner
muchos transistores en un solo chip de
silicio ese microprocesador
va a revolucionar el mundo para el año
2009 74 aparece la primera computadora
del álter 8000 todas las computadoras
evolucionaron a partir de esa para darse
una idea el nombre alter derivaba de un
capítulo de viaje a las estrellas eso
demuestra la seriedad que tenían los
hacker en aquella época
este chip empieza a evolucionar y para
la década del 80 explota el
microprocesador empieza a dominar todas
las etapas del mundo porque abaratará la
computación y empieza de la década del
hardware pero mientras existe la década
del hardware se empiezan a especializar
las computadoras en alguna cosa aparece
los software de procesamiento de texto y
murió la máquina de escribir aparecen
las planillas electrónicas de cálculo y
las empresas se convierten en verdaderos
centros de este de finanzas aparece el
software de diseño asistido y cambia la
arquitectura
entonces empieza a mostrarse un rasgo de
la computación lo que diferencia a las
computadoras es el software entonces
saltamos a la década siguiente que
podemos llamar la década del software el
primero que se da cuenta de la
importancia del software es bill gates y
eso lo convierte en el hombre más rico
del mundo básicamente él sabía que ya
un puñado de programadores no podían
programar todas las computadoras de todo
el mundo sino que había que hacer
programas enlatados que solucionarán los
problemas de mucha gente en los 90
empieza a aparecer otro fenómeno las
computadoras dejan de estar aisladas y
ser personales empiezan a juntarse en
redes de computadoras primero aparece en
la red de área local lo que se llaman
locales area networks después las redes
metropolitanas y después termina
desembocando en un fenómeno que es www
world wide web' y empieza la siguiente
era la década primera de este siglo es
la década de internet internet empieza a
abaratar las comunicaciones y empieza a
desarrollar un montón de nuevos negocios
y nuevas aperturas con la evolución de
internet empieza a crecer más el mundo
de la conectividad y aparecen las dos
estrellas de esta década
primero desarrollamos la fibra óptica la
fibra óptica es un pequeño milagro de la
electrónica que permite llevar mucha
información muy lejos a un costo muy
bajo los smartphones nos permiten tener
en nuestro bolsillo una máquina que nos
conecta sin conectividad por supuesto
yandel wifi con toda la información que
queramos en el momento que queramos y
del lugar que queramos entonces podemos
decir que esta década de la década de la
fibra óptica y del smartphone los
smartphones se conectan de dos maneras
una barata que es el uso el wifi cuando
llegan a cualquier lugar cuando alguien
llega un asado hay dos cosas que
pregunta primero la primera vez cuál es
la clave del wifi
la segunda que hay de comer esta tarde
lo importante es saber cambiar de eliana
a tiempo darse cuenta cuál de las
tecnologías va dominando en cada momento
es un poco caótico al parecer pero como
todas las cosas debes seguir un conjunto
de normas y leyes cuáles son las leyes
que gobiernan el mundo digital con
nosotros estudiamos física nos enseñaron
las leyes de newton sobre las leyes de
newton edificamos todo el edificio de la
mecánica después apareció un clérigo
llamando mendel que empezó a estudiar
y sobre los estudios del montamos el
mundo de la genética apareció un hombre
que se llama kepler en europa y sobre
las leyes que él definió construimos el
auto de la astrofísica y se desarrolló
la carrera espacial
si el mundo físico se desarrolló sobre
leyes concretas cuáles serán las leyes
que gobiernan el mundo digital que crece
aceleradamente la primera ley la más
conocida se llama la ley de moore la la
lanzó uno de los fundadores de intel y
dijo sencillamente una cosa la cantidad
de transistores que iba a haber en un
chip de computación se iban a duplicar
cada año cuando él lanzó la ley era el
mil 965 y los transistores que entraban
en un chip eran 64 máximo en el año 2000
35 años después había 55 millones de
transistores en un chip el 21 4 aparece
otra ley de un señor que se llama mail
café
él inventó la ethernet y él dijo que el
valor de una red iba a ser proporcional
a la cantidad de usuarios de la red al
cuadrado después que aparece otra otra
ley en los 90 que le decían la ley de
andy y bill empezó como una humorada
como un chiste de las conferencias de
computación decía que todo lo que
fabricaba andy grove que era el ceo de
intel y larga o un chip cada vez más
potente cada dos años al doble de
capacidad aparece un señor que se llama
bill gates que era deseo de microsoft
diseña un software que se chupaba toda
la potencia del nuevo chip
hacía cosas que antes no podían hacerlo
software y volvía obsoleto a los chips
automáticamente acá está la sucesión de
los chips que lanzaban di y las cosas
que hacía hábil para consumir el poder
del chip y trabajaban sin con
sincronizadamente en el adiós mil
aparece un señor se llama wilder
enunciado una nueva ley él dice que el
ancho de banda que va a haber en el
mundo se va a duplicar cada cuatro meses
y eso se probaba porque en el año 2002
circulaba en un par de fibra óptica más
información que la circulaba en todo
internet en 1997 cuatro años antes
transferir transferir un gigabyte de
información entre los ángeles y boston
en el año 70 costaba un millón y medio
de dólares en el año 2000 costaba 26
centavos de dólar y tenía un pensamiento
interesante él postula que en todas las
eras se basan en que hay algo que es
abundante hay una abundancia clave y hay
una escasez clave en la era
preindustrial lo abundante era la tierra
lo escaso eran los caballos de fuerza
para darlas cuando aparece la revolución
industrial empieza a bajar el costo del
caballo de fuerza los caballos de fuerza
se hacen cada vez más baratos y en el
medio de la revolución industrial el
costo de un caballo de fuerza ya estaba
en siete centavos de dólar entonces
empezamos a producir cosas usando la
fuerza mecánica por ejemplo un telar
industrial y destruimos todo el trabajo
de las personas que usaban telares
manuales las mujeres les gusta tener más
prendas en su closet entonces es es la
consecuencia natural lo mismo pasó con
la telefonía los viejos teléfonos usaban
cables de cobre que podían llevar cuatro
kilos hertz de ancho de banda los
celulares actuales pueden bajar
capacidades
15 o 20 mega fácilmente depende cuánto
se les haya compitiendo por la misma
celda el problema que el entusiasmo de
hitler hizo que mucha gente invirtiera
en infraestructura de fibra y para año
2000 es ocurre en la explosión de
internet lo que llama el dot com boom y
la mayoría de las compañías que habían
invertido pierden todo lo que habían
apostado entonces hitler queda olvidado
cuál fue el problema de hitler el
problema de wilder fue que se lanzó una
infraestructura sin que hubiera la
suficiente capacidad de consumo es como
la ley de andy pero sin build
el problema que es infraestructura
recién se volvió necesaria entre 7 y 8
años después cuando aparecen dos cosas
youtube y netflix que son los que
empiezan a transmitir vídeo por las
redes de alta velocidad
entonces la vuelven a ser escasas y hay
una quinta ley es de mi autoría es una
ley bastarda porque no ha sido
reconocida por el mundo
pero esta ley dice que las vacas no
siguen la ley de moore o
eso quiere decir que no dan el doble de
carne cada dos años ni comen la mitad de
pasto esta es la explicación empírica de
miles este es una vaca acabe en una
laptop en el año 2000 una vaca en
argentina costaba 200 dólares y una
laptop costaba 2000 en el año 2010 yo
una vaca ya costaba mil dólares y las
laptop habían bajado a 500 dólares en
año 2002 yo necesitaba 20 10 vacas para
llevarme una laptop
hoy en día con una vaca tengo dos laptop
los términos de intercambio vaca laptops
cambiaron 20 veces en menos de 10 años
todas estas leyes sirven para explicar
qué pasó en el pasado pero sirven para
extrapolar en el futuro qué cosas vemos
en el futuro qué cosas estas leyes no
dicen si aún la ley de mercas si una red
es muy importante conectando a n
personas su límite va a ser la población
mundial pero si ahora empezamos a
conectar más cosas la cafetera de la
gente el auto de la gente el horno de la
gente todas las pertenencias de las
personas vamos a tener una red
infinitamente más rica que nos dice la
ley de moore la ley de moore nos dice
que van a aparecer computadoras cada vez
más potentes que van a poder hacer cosas
que antes no hacían las demás hoy en día
una computadora puede identificarnos la
cara una computadora puede leer nuestras
huellas digitales e identificarnos
positivamente una computadora puede
seguir la mirada de nuestros ojos y
aceptar comandos las computadoras
aumentan su capacidad entonces lo que
dice
la otra ley de wilder lo aplicamos al
vídeo es ahora producimos más vídeos a
menor costo eso nos va
lo que se llama la microsegmentación a
cada uno le van a mandar un vídeo para
vender algo que uno necesita comprar
cuando lo necesita comprar imagínense
cuando uno iba al cine en los años 70
agarramos el diario buscamos las
películas que estaban en estreno y había
15-16 salas que uno podía visitar que le
quedaban cerca de su casa y le insumirá
toda la tarde entre que iba al cine
sacaba las entradas olvida del cine
hoy en día agarramos netflix y la
cantidad de oferta de películas que nos
da es tan abrumadora que a veces
terminamos sin ver ninguna
el corolario de esto de la ley de
horacio es si las cosas escasas son las
cosas que realmente tienen valor que hay
más escaso para los seres humanos que
nuestra salud y nuestra vida
vamos a aplicar todos los conocimientos
digitales en alargar nuestra vida siglo
20 ha sido un siglo contradictorio hemos
inventado unas cosas que nos han
alargado la vida las cloacas
inicialmente los rayos x la penicilina
las tecnologías de diagnóstico por
imágenes el trasplante de horno de
órganos el mapeo de adn pero también
inventamos unas cosas para cortar la
vida inventamos el sedentarismo
inventamos la obesidad del tabaquismo
mejoramos este la cantidad alcohol que
podemos tomar organizamos las previas de
los adolescentes para que empiecen a
vivir menos inventamos la comida
chatarra aumentamos la contaminación
ambiental hubo más accidentes por la
velocidad y también introdujimos las
drogas peligrosas a pesar de eso vamos
ganando la vida se alargó un 24 por
ciento desde el año 60 hasta ahora la
vida promedio del ser humano en el año
60 eran unos 66 años de vida
edad promedio hoy es 82 en el mundo
civilizado 78 en las zonas periféricas
como la nuestra pero ya estamos 55 por
ciento de diferencia en el año 60 en
latinoamérica la vida promedio en 53
años o sea que nosotros estamos haciendo
un catch up entonces hemos visto que
hemos atravesado una jungla digital por
estos últimos 50 años es un viaje con
avances y retrocesos pero que a la larga
nos ha dado mucha satisfacción
y yo para despedirme voy a terminar con
una analogía
dicen que todas las mañanas en el áfrica
se levanta una gacela
ese día la gacela sabe que tiene que
correr más rápido que el león más rápido
porque si no se la comen pero también se
levanta un león
y el león sabe esa mañana que él tiene
que correr más rápido que la gacela más
lenta porque si no no come la moraleja
es que no importa que ustedes sean
gacelas o leones despiértense y empiezan
a correr
[Aplausos]
[Música]